a possible birth control breakthrough so
women have always had the responsibility
with hills hatches yes iuds now we could
be closer to birth control for men
specifically in a pill form
researchers say they've developed a pill
that blocks a vitamin A producing Gene
needed for conception it was given
orally to male mice for four weeks
researchers say dramatically reduce
sperm counts now we've taken a turn
99 effective in preventing pregnancy
without harmful side effects the mice
could be fathers again could after four
to six weeks after they stop receiving
the compound clinical trials for humans
could begin within six months Nate you
had a little something to say about it
that's a great idea what do you think I
have a couple of friends that are team
no kids and they'll be popping them like
tic-tac-toe I don't know man I don't
like that four to six weeks to get your
boys back on the field yeah I think you
need yeah it says could I also think
reducing the boys is a problem for a lot
of boys
it is about time but it won't be me it
won't be